yes I want to I'm just calling because
when I have Cedars and I went on the
seizures yeah I'll Anton okay
no I'm Capra again yeah yeah and they I
was they started when I'm when I was 36
and I just turned 38 and right now I'm
currently taking I weigh 175 pounds I'm
taking the healthy brain and heart and
I'm taking this adaptive but I was I
don't know recommended the daily classic
and also the they're more Italian and I
haven't taken it yet but I just curious
on what the quantities I should be
taking other stuff listen out there how
much you ate yeah having 25 pounds um
six one okay any other issues any arts
writers have a pressure diabetes no
other than like when I lay down to go to
sleep order I feel like my I can't
swallow my my saliva I can't get rid of
my saliva you know okay when you sleep
sitting up do you bypass that symptom um
a little bit yeah sometimes during the
day I kind of will I'll be able to
swallow okay but then when I go to sleep
order and it's kind of hard
first of all the medications you're
taking just you know allow the guys who
prescribe to you to monitor you on a
regular basis as they suggested and and
have them reduce the medication are
eliminated as they see fit
in the meantime Charmaine what foods
would you add to Chris's diet to
maximize the nutrition for the brain
eggs eggs and butter eggs and butter you
got it
and so I'd go ahead and 175 pounds Chris
you should probably take 12 to 15 eggs a
day it can be soft scramble and butter
that could be a soft soft poached with
soft yolks they can be a soft soft
boiled with soft soft yolks
you got to watch it if you eat scrambled
eggs and ham
restaurants and things like that they're
60% oil and only 20% a powder and 20%
wheat flour just exactly what you don't
want in a maximize your absorption by
getting gluten-free no wheat brother
right oats and I would kind of change
your recipe a little bit what would you
give him chard to support healthy rain
function here 175 pounds Wow
you take as I give thee he's takin a
ultimate daily classic isn't he and he
said he had this adaptive yep okay what
else did you give him fresh brain yeah
HGH well I would give him two healthy
paydirt heart packs
well that's he has taken one he said he
was taking that no I didn't hear I
didn't hear Christianity first are you
taking a healthy brain and heart pack I
have that yeah he said you had that okay
I'm sorry I didn't hear that they need
to those your body weight you'll need to
those full dose or anything twice a day
and then of course for vascular problems
in the brain would be the ultimate daily
classic what you're doing I'd go ahead
and take three of those twice a day
would be two battles a month and that's
adaptive how many synaptic would you
have Chris takes your main um I take a
couple times I haven't take for a to
twice a day yeah you twice today any two
bottles a month to the synaptic and this
designed to be the raw material to your
brain cells and spinal cord cells make
neurotransmitters so your brain cells
can talk to each other the eggs are very
important I and you should not be on any
statin drugs to lower cholesterol your
cholesterol should be over over 200
should be like 250 to 350 s where you
want to be when you have acquired
seizures like you got your seizures when
you were 27 28 years old this is almost
always a nutritional deficiency so it's
imperative is to stay away from the bad
foods including gluten we burn around
hos to maximize your Commission see get
those eggs which is going to give you
the raw materials to help your body
restore brain health 75% of your brain
weight is the white matter the
insulation material the frame myelin
which is over
most 100% cholesterol so you do need to
get those eggs with good soft yolks
absolutely no frying no oils and so
forth and and call us in two weeks in
four weeks in six weeks
any time your doctor adjust your
medications aren't so heavy you might
try going without it for a couple of
days and see but let that you know the
doctor prescribe your anti-seizure
medication but I can be the one or her
either one to decide to lower your
medication or try going without it for a
week or so that's let them decide that
don't you or I decide that okay and
let's see here goes calling a couple
weeks in mobile kitchens Chris